أسقط المطرقة
أو لا ، مرحبًا ، ما يحدث
الآن
يظهر فيديو كاميرا الجسد الشرطة
تكافح مع مهاجم بول بيلوسي
بعد أن شاهدت
شرطة الاعتداء ترد على منزل بيلوسي
في حوالي الساعة 2:30 صباحًا في 28 أكتوبر بعد أن اتصل
بول بيلوسي بالرقم 9-1-  1 أبلغت أن أحد
المهاجمين قد اقتحم
منزلهم في سان فرانسيسكو
هنا فقط في انتظار عودة زوجتي ، آه إنه
فقط ينتظر
عودتها لذا لن تكون هنا
ليوم واحد لذا أعتقد أنني سأنتظر 82
يبدو أن زوج نانسي بيلوسي الذي كان يبلغ من العمر عامًا في ذلك الوقت يحاول إرسال إشارة إلى
المرسل 9-1-1 بأنه يحتاج إلى المساعدة
دون إزعاج الدخيل ، فهذه هي
شرطة الكابيتول حوالي عام 2 20.
زوجتي
لم يخبرني بإغلاق الهاتف وترى
ما قاله بعد ذلك قبل أن
يغلق الهاتف يقاطع الدخيل
أنا صديق لهم ، وقد
تم اتهام الدخيل ديفيد ديباب
بالاعتداء ومحاولة القتل من بين أمور
أخرى  وقد دفع بأنه غير مذنب
في جميع التهم بعد إلقاء القبض عليه ،
أخبر باب الشرطة أنه كان بالخارج للحصول على رئيسة مجلس النواب آنذاك
نانسي بيلوسي واقتبس
أهدافًا أخرى وكرر نظريات مؤامرة لا أساس لها
حول تجسس بيلوسي والديمقراطيين
على حملة ترامب
[تصفيق]
قال إنه  أيقظت بول بيلوسي وكنت
أبحث عن زوجته ، كل ما كنت سأقوم به
لسحب رهينةهم بشكل أساسي وكنت
سأتحدث معها وأخبرها بشكل أساسي
بما أفعله وأخبرت أن
ديبايب قد نشر سابقًا
نظريات مؤامرة حول هجوم السادس من يناير في  في
مبنى الكابيتول الأمريكي على حسابه على Facebook ،
أخبر الشرطة عندما غادرت منزلي
تحدثت نانسي بيلوسي مع كريس والاس من CNN
حول الهجوم الذي وقع قبل أسبوع ،
كيف حال زوجك بول ، إنه
بخير ، سيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت
حتى يعود إلى طبيعته  أشعر
بحزن شديد حيال ذلك لأن الشخص كان
يبحث عني وعن زوجي العزيز
الذي لم
يدفع الثمن السياسي فعلاً بول بيلوسي
خضع لعملية جراحية بعد الهجوم
لكسر في الجمجمة وإصابات خطيرة في
ذراعه اليمنى ويديه وهو مصاب.
شوهد وهو يرتدي قبعة في المناسبات مع
زوجته في الأشهر الأخيرة ، قالت إنها
لن تشاهد الفيديو الذي يظهر الهجوم
وليس لدي أي نية على الإطلاق
لرؤية هذا الاعتداء المميت على
حياة زوجي فيرونيكا ميراكلز سي إن إن سان
فرانسيسكو